come on am i plugged in is this plugged
in you plugged in yeah let me try it
again
you
hello everybody welcome back we're to
the finals of the Allegheny region
competition we have the final three
teams who will now do the ten minute
presentations the winner will receive
$50,000 to advance the innovation and
but each team has already won an
opportunity to compete at the national
level for additional prizes so with that
I would like to move right on to
introduce their first team who's already
Baum and Reed laughs from Case Western
[Applause]
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Prince Kosh and I'm the founder
and CEO of boundary labs we're a startup
spun out of research done at Case
Western Reserve University today I'm
here to tell you how we're about to
redefine aerodynamics so the main
problem that we're trying to address is
the fact that wind energy still isn't
cost-effective enough to compete with
fossil fuels on a consumer level we
really see this as a function of two
major issues one wind turbines suffer
from aerodynamic drag and are thereby
less efficient and two at high wind
speeds turbines have to go through
expensive breaking cycles leading to
more wear and tear and higher operating
costs we saw this as an incredible
industry to enter really because of the
fact that there's about that there's
about 80 gigawatts of wind currently
installed in the u.s. today with over
50,000 plus operational turbines up and
running well we're really interested in
though is the wind turbine blade market
this is a market that's projected to
grow by about 43 percent by 2020 with
over a 10 percent annual growth in
installed capacity over the next five
years alone so what does our technology
actually do well we've developed is a
flexible adhesive plasma actuator that
regulates flow over wind turbine blades
that's a bit complex so let me explain
what it really does well we've design is
a thin flexible solid-state electrode
that can be applied right to the surface
of wind turbine blades as seen in this
picture on the left when activated the
electrodes ionize a thin layer of non
thermal plasma over the surface of the
blade and control the airflow with
electric fields this results in an
improvement of low wind speed
performance by about four percent and
also is able to protect the turbine at
high wind speeds by actually inducing
drag thereby slowing down the RPMs of
the turbine and leading to less braking
costs we currently have a provisional
patent application filed for our
technology and are working with our
University's IP venture clinic to file
for a full patent application so what
does this really look like in this image
on the left you can see a typical test
wind turbine blade that we've developed
in a winter in a wind tunnel test
what I really want to point your
attention to is that turbulent dense air
flowing on top of that turbine on the
left on top of the turbine blade on the
left now this is that exact same turbine
blade with our technology on and
activated with the use of electric
fields what we're able to do is generate
that thin layer of plasma delay the
boundary layer separation point increase
the overall lift of the blade and
thereby maximum power output we see her
Pat's a success as broken down into five
main stages phase one is a conception of
an idea the development of a white paper
raising a bit of funding and also going
through the NSF Iker program where we
conducted over 40 customer interviews
with really key executives and major
wind energy producers and OEMs speaking
to the folks who would make the
executive decisions on the business and
technical side of whether this
technology was feasible or not stage 2
is where we're at right now over the
past few months and into the summer
we'll be conducting extensive R&D
testing focused on degradation and
optimization in partnership with NASA
Glenn Research Center in Cleveland phase
3 is the first time our tech goes up and
on a turbine we're seeking to partner
with a wind energy producer to have our
actuators up and on blades in lieu of
stage 4 where we'll be able to get our
actuators on an entire wind farm
targeting turbines that were bought
under older Power Purchase Agreements
and that are smaller in size about the
hundred to 150 kilowatt range so that
the turbine operators can maximize the
amount of energy output on those
turbines before their 20-year lifespan
is over our eventual and final goal doe
is stage 5 what we want to do is
eventually partner up with an OEM so
that our technology can be integrated
straight into the wind turbine blade
designs in terms of financials this is
really broken up into three major
segments phase one is where we're at
right now proof of concept and customer
discovery we're all money one and raised
through R and B we're all money one and
raised goes straight towards R&D phase
two is where we'll be this summer and
into the next year of a wind operator
partnership where we'll be making a
certain we'll be making a profit based
off the individual revenue uptake on
each installed turbine but we'll be
overall cash negative because all that
money is going to continue straight into
R&D
optimisation of our technology in lieu
of stage 3
our third final stage at this point will
be cash positive because all of our
individual in-house manufacturing and
R&D will be eased back as we transition
into an IP license of our technology
straight with a wind turbine om so
Siemens gamesa GE so and so forth
the value proposition that we're putting
forward is really two-faced space one is
we're able to we're able to offer
enhance control over blade velocity and
phase two is we're able to reduce
aerodynamic drag over turbines with no
moving parts whatsoever this results in
two things decrease costs and increase
revenue the major factors in decrease
costs are lowered great usage and
maintenance times and those for
increased revenue are widened cut in and
cut out speed ranges increase
operational time and maximization of
energy output
this is a typical wind turbine power
curve that any wind energy producers
used to seeing now this is that same
curve with our technology on and
activated by lowering the minimum
cutting speed and increasing the maximum
cut out speed for these turbines we're
able to maximize the amount of area
under the curve and juice out every
single kilowatt of energy that these
turbines can produce through extensive
industry analysis we've come to realize
that some of the major competitors in
the wind energy industry fight for even
a one percent improvement in aerodynamic
efficiency we're confident that the four
percent we'll be able to offer will be
strongly adopted by the market what I'm
really excited to tell you about though
is some of the societal impacts our
technology has if 100 percent of wind
turbines in American have can have our
actuators on them this will lead to an
equivalent of 16 coal power plants being
displaced off the grid five million plus
cars worth of emissions taken off the
road which generates enough excess
energy to power the state of Illinois
nine times over some of our major
competition on the direct side comes
from a small start-up up in Connecticut
focused on using similar boundary layer
manipulation technology to control it to
control airflow through the IP that
we've filed we've been able to not only
do that but also offer protection from
high wind speeds by actually inducing
drag rather than reducing it and slowing
down the RPMs that those turbines have
to go through on the in direct
competition slide a lot of that comes
from advancements from major OEMs VOC
on pitch control improvements lighter
materials and mechanical improvements
the big thing here is that while all of
these advancements are small and steady
they're impossible they're nearly
impossible to be integrated into the
entire existing turbine fleet that's up
and functional right now that's where
our technology comes in some of the
really interesting use cases for defense
that I want to quickly touch base about
today are really the traditional active
flow control over mid sized UAVs so the
reaper over here on the left
improving aerodynamic efficiency to
lower fuel costs but then this case on
the right over here a couple of weeks
ago we had a chance to speak to a few
Air Force pilots at our payee
Department of Energy conference we were
at and we found out from them that when
performing mid-air refueling maneuvers a
lot of the wake and wash of the airflow
coming off of the boom system so that
cylinder you see from the tanker to the
jet causes a lot of unsteady turbulence
for the fighter jet pilot themselves
we're seeking to apply our actuators
onto the boom to smoothen and streamline
that flow making it safer for the pilots
and making the overall fueling system
more efficient we think that we can do
so with the total budget about of about
$15,000 with the main line-item rehear
coming in through Windtunnel rent time
over at NASA Glenn Research Center like
I mentioned earlier we're team comprised
of undergraduate master's and PhD
students in mechanical engineering
aerospace engineering data science
material science and business we're also
advised by a phenomenal team of business
advisors strategic advisors legal
mentors and technical advisors
particularly dr. Mario Garcia saans
our technical adviser who's a
world-renowned expert in energy and
control systems and a current technical
director at RPE the US Department of
Energy's Advanced Research Projects
Agency ladies and gentlemen my name is
Prince Ghosh and I'm the founder and CEO
of boundary labs I have a vision that
one day every single wind turbine in
America will have our technology on it
I'm hoping that each and every one of
you can join me on that journey thank
you so much
[Applause]
next thank you very much for that next
we have a team from Carnegie Mellon
ecotone
hello I'm a Sasha Cohen une Douce and
I'm Dylan Liu and we are ecotone
renewables so personally I've never
eaten an apple core and I bet that many
of you haven't either but just because
we don't eat this court doesn't mean
that it shouldn't have value why should
we throw it away when we can turn it
into something else that would benefit
us currently 16 percent of families in
the United States are food insecure
and yet we're wasting a 40 percent of
our food supply why are we paying to
waste cause excess amounts of traffic
congestion and also rely on unsuitable
sources of energy if we're putting all
this time energy and money into
producing nutritious food for the people
of this country we see this as an
amazing opportunity to capitalize by
converting this energy on or near site
until now the main solution has been to
set has been to ship away this waste
into centralized facilities like
landfills but the centralization has way
too many externalities and so we propose
a new solution the solution is called
the sea horse the sea horse takes
otherwise wasted time energy and money
and it puts it back into the food system
for every meal we can be saving
restaurants 25 cents and waste hauling
fees producing 100 kilojoules of energy
and also producing a quarter of a quart
of fertilizer this all fits neatly into
a 10 by 10 foot shipping container which
is just slightly larger than the average
dumpster this system can divert 12 tons
of food waste a year creating a $30,000
revenue stream of fertilizer in
continually producing energy sufficient
enough to cut nearly all electricity
costs for a small business we are
helping other businesses in society by
avoiding high hauling costs avoiding
odor and externality risks and as well
as capital and time overruns we have a
high return on investments than other
renewable energy resources as we sell
fertilizer which is easily marketable
and beneficial to local communities we
also reduce energy costs and emissions
which in turn improves both individual
and communal energy security we are
currently partnered with an anaerobic
digestion
company in Seattle called impact
bioenergy our partnership allows us to
practice and license at no cost because
we're using their patented gas cleaning
separation and scrubbing technology as
well as their tank layouts and
electrical design we're taking their
designs and we're scaling them down so
that they're more accessible to smaller
businesses so that these businesses can
improve their energy ecotone renewables
is working to improve our designs so
that we can work with permitting and
policy standards so that this design is
accessible in urban areas there is no
other system on the market that
capitalizes off of both energy and
fertilizer byproducts as you can see on
this chart the x-axis represents social
and economic benefits while the y-axis
represents degrees of locality the more
local the solution the less amount of
time and money we are spending on having
a negative impact on the environment the
higher the benefit the more we the
people are getting out of our waste
removal practices on the bottom left you
can see that we are paying to waste
these renewable resources and so we want
to deploy scale appropriate systems so
that we can receive as many benefits as
possible currently organizations have
been paying fuel tipping and waste
hauling fees and we want to remove these
fees and externality costs we're
allowing we are allowing organizations
to return their investment within one
and a half years Germany is currently
the only other country in the world that
does commercial anaerobic digestion so
we took their market and apply those
ratios to the United States giving us a
thirty four billion dollar national
market we took that into our serviceable
available market which focuses on
restaurants apartment complexes college
dormitories and three distributors
because they all waste in between 10 and
15 tons of food a year they all have an
internal call to action it is also
completely possible for them to separate
their wastes because countries like
Sweden Norway and Portugal are already
doing this and we're allowing them to
receive additional revenue through
fertilizer and decrease their energy
costs the average restaurant can say
four and a half thousand dollars a month
on removing waste hauling fees alone we
have three revenues
dreams the first of which is the sale of
our seahorse system in addition we offer
the market users a platform we have an
operation subscription which allows
sorry about this we have an operation
subscription where we take control of
the operation of the system in exchange
for 9% of the revenue based on these
revenue streams we expect to sell 40 sea
horses by year 5 and reduced production
costs by year 4 we are receiving weekly
interest from both local and
international companies and we expect
this interest to grow this is because
society is pressing for these
sustainable solutions the u.s. is aiming
on having 17% of its energy be renewably
sourced by 2023 states and numerous
European countries have already banned
organic scraps and landfills and to make
this solution even more accessible due
to its compact size we are avoiding many
of the costly permits which applied to
more larger scale industrial systems our
team is comprised of a diverse set of
skills with students from Carnegie
Mellon the University of Pittsburgh and
the University of Michigan in addition
to our team we have three advisors the
first of which dr. Deborah Stein has
worked for the white house is a
Technology Policy specialist and
currently works for the Scott Institute
for energy innovation dr. Leanne
Gilbertson at the Swanson School of
Engineering helps us establish local
connections while we work closely on her
designs with Jan Allen a civil engineer
from impact bioenergy our partners
include impact bioenergy the local
forward to food rescue which connects us
to over 300 restaurants in Pittsburgh as
well as the national repair the world
which connects us to communal gardens
across the country we have currently
raised over $100,000 on our system
design and we have deployed Pittsburgh's
first portable aquaponics farm this will
also be our first seahorse site and
we're excited to see where a project can
go from there we are ecotone renewables
we are closing the food loop and we are
creating a 21st century food system
thank you
[Applause]
thank you lassen final presentation team
is for waste list from the Penn State
University
okay
everyone poops and this is a serious
problem when it comes to energy and
water conservation in the u.s. water is
typically treated and then transported
to us homes a portion of this water goes
to outdoor activities and the rest of it
becomes waste water the average person
living in the US produces about 70
gallons of water per day and of this the
large the toilet is the largest
contributor so let's see how this scales
each person like I said flushes seven
has 70 gallons of wastewater per day and
of this twenty of twenty gallons goes
down the toilet so if someone has a 450
annual water bill per person fifty of
those dollars are going down the toilet
with a population of 327 million people
in the u.s. that 70 gallons becomes 2023
billion gallons of wastewater each day
and 6.1 billion gallons of twat of water
flush down the toilet it takes water
must be treated and then transported
before it returns back to the home and
this process takes a lot of energy it
takes ten billion kilowatt hours of
energy just for that toilet water cycle
in dollar in in terms of dollars that's
1.2 billion dollars worth of electricity
toilet manufacturers and government
regulations have been making efforts to
reduce the toilets water footprints but
still we either need copious amounts of
water or high pressure flushes so to
reduce the toilets water footprint while
maintaining a clean toilet surface we
need a slippery coating so to address
this issue we've produced what we call
the liquid entrenched porous surface
which we refer to as less as you can see
on the left toilet conventional toilet
surfaces are prone to residue build-up
foul odors and the accumulation of
disease-causing bacteria if they're not
regularly maintained but our coating
stands out from its pure hydrophobic
coating technologies and its ability to
repel solid waste in addition to liquid
waste any residue that does attach to
our surface can be washed away with 90
percent less water than I can
toilet surface so this is how our
coating compares to a conventional
surface but you might be wondering how
does it compare to a state-of-the-art
hydrophobic coating so as we see here
our surface outperforms even the
state-of-the-art super hydrophobic
surfaces and slippery smooth surfaces
here in terms of its solid repellency so
our coating leaves less residue and that
means it requires less water to clean it
we further validated our technology
through a collaboration with Cranfield
University this group received funding
from the Gates Foundation for the
reinvent the toilet challenge and they
reached out to us with this particular
issue of fecal residue on the toilet
bowl so in their tests they drop human
waste onto a surface on two different
surfaces and they allow the surface to
slide and then they see how much residue
was left over and as you can see on all
of the other surfaces they tested all of
the way sticks but on our surface all of
that waste slides away but even in the
case that we had some residue left on
our surface it would still take up to
90% less water to clean our surface
compared to the state of the art so for
households rental managers universities
large-scale institutions basically
anyone who's footing a water bill toilet
surface that can suit can consume 90
percent less water would mean money
savings but at the national scale it
would also lead to large-scale energy
savings we've already filed a patent on
this coating and as you can see here
from this video ira coating can already
be applied to toilets we are planning to
conduct further customer discovery in
conjunction with some technical
optimizations to see what coating method
our customers would prefer our current
plan is to first conduct a pilot test at
our home institution of Penn State
University and we've already started
making arrangements with our custodial
manager there if this is successful we
intend to reach out to other
universities leveraging the reach and
the leadership that this custodial
manager has with the Big Ten Network and
also setting janitorial standards
other institutions and once we've made
some initial sales in this in
institutions we'd like to extend our
reach into retail and eventually we want
to see our coding in every toilet in the
country when it comes to large scales if
you consider Penn State University we
have a student enrollment of over 46,000
students and that means that on one day
we're flushing almost one school day
we're flushing almost a million gallons
of water down the toilet in energy in
terms of energy alone that means we're
flushing away almost seventy thousand
dollars and we can save a lot of this
with our coding however based on
interviews over a hundred customers that
we've already conducted through our
experience in the National I Corps
program we do understand that we can add
significantly more value to institutions
by reducing the labor associated with
cleaning the toilets at the individual
individual level we can save homeowners
significant amounts of money per year
just on their water bills and nationally
these savings would extend to instead of
spending flushing trillions of dollars
down the toilet each year we could be
flushing significantly less from a
potential savings perspective if our
coding were applied to all of the
toilets in the United States
institutions and workplaces would see
savings potential savings of seven and a
half billion dollars households would
see 15 billion dollars of savings and
our plan is to price our product based
on these possible savings allowing the
end user to keep some of these savings
and then we would keep the rest as
revenue to get a little bit more
specific in terms of our financial goals
we intend to focus our first focus our
first year on developing a Minimum
Viable Product for institutions our
second our second year would be set
spent optimizing this MVP in developing
a commercial product for institutions
while also working on tweaking this
commercial product into an MVP for
households and retail in our in our
third year we hope to have reliable
institutional skills sales
there are a number of non market drivers
for this particular technology at the
institutional level all the way up to
the national level for example at our
home institution of Penn State there are
a number a number of energy saving
initiatives as well as committees
dedicated to making sure that the
university makes choices that promote
reduction in energy and also reduced
water consumption at the national level
there are also policies in place such as
the Energy Policy Act of 1992 which sets
a limit on how much toilets can flush
can send away per flush there are also
other programs that incentivize reducing
this flush volume even further from what
the policy prescribes our team is
composed of a number of PhD students all
of us have a material science background
we have a professor on our team from
mechanical engineering and our mentor
has had 20 plus years of startup
experience we've worked on a number of
projects together both in the lab and
outside such as in the iCore program so
far we've been developing our technology
since 2015 and we've also been
validating it through various
experiments and with this reinvent the
toilet challenge through camp our
collaborators at Cranfield University
and our next steps are - we have some
technical milestones which include
conducting this pilot test at Penn State
and we also have a number of business
milestones as well currently we are
participating in the Ben Franklin tech
stellarator program where our goal is to
surround ourselves with experts and
advisors with that can fill in the gaps
in our team and give us additional
experience and up and expertise we'll
also be looking into different aspects
of our supply chain structure and also
regulations relevant to our product but
ultimately we want to revolutionize the
way that waste is managed with a coating
like ours toilets may one day be able to
keep themselves clean while reducing
their environmental impact thank you
[Applause]
let's thank our team for a great
presentation thank you so please give us
a few minutes to determine the results
of the judging good luck to everyone
very good excellent innovative ideas
thank you
good afternoon everyone so it's about
5:30 at 6 o'clock we have our next
speaker it's
Falacci Ganapathy who is the head the
world head of HR for global
effectiveness from tata consultancy
services I wanted to make sure everyone
was going to be staying to see that in
the next few minutes we're very excited
he should be arriving any moment we're
also going to be announcing our poster
winners we had 46 posters today so quite
a few that came in at the last minute
it's causing a we're making sure that
we've got everything calculated so we'll
be back with you in just a minute to
make that announcement as well
sustainability weekend does kick off
with Balaji's talk at six o'clock
immediately following between 7:00 and
8:00 there's a reception in rangos 3 on
the other side of this wall they're
getting that set up and then tomorrow
there are sessions and panels all day so
for those of you who are still in town
and particularly those of you that are
students sustainability weekend is
really shaping up to be a pretty great
cup of great afternoon morning and
afternoon I should say they're starting
tomorrow morning around 9:30 in the
morning and they have a series of panels
and a keynote again over lunch I believe
tomorrow so some very good programming
for those of you who have been with us
for most of the week really want to
thank you for being here and we're very
excited for all of the successful
sessions the great speakers the keynotes
etc that we had as well as evening
events etc there were some tours today
that I think what particularly well and
we've got a lot of good things coming up
for you in 2019 because energy week will
be March 25th through 29th of 2019 so
with that if you'll give us just a
couple of minutes please hang tight not
time to leave yet we are going to make
these announcements particularly those
of you with posters as well we want to
make sure you all hang out just a few
minutes so we can make those
announcements thank you
you
our poster winners are still here if not
let's still give a round of applause for
them so for all of our all of our
posters so in the category of best
undergraduate poster receiving an award
of 250 dollars we have Rihanna and
Barney and the poster is Pittsburgh to
Paris reducing the carbon footprint of
CMU so is Johanna Barney here you are
come on up
[Applause]
congratulations so there was a second
student on that poster valishia lee
congratulations ladies
[Applause]
so in the next category in the four best
masters student again for 250 dollars is
ro heat guard and the pret the poster is
grip ballast autonomous load control on
grid resilience so israa heat here is
her heat here he missed a golden
opportunity to come up with stage he get
his picture taken
so congratulations okay so we have a tie
for second place a tie for second place
so these were equal in point value I'm
going to have to read one before the
other but they are equal in point value
so for second place for $500 we have
yeon wang and the poster is development
a regression model to correlate
molecular properties with flammability
or liquid eligibility
is that you come on up
yes come on
can you take a picture of us in front of
them yeah let's do here
thank you so for the winners of that
first poster if you guys will come back
up we'll get a better picture before we
leave alright so in a tie for second
place $500 is jacob wart on-demand
ride-sharing has reduced per capital
vehicle registration and gasoline is
Jacob Ward here Jacob Ward again another
missed opportunity for a picture up on
stage congratulations take it away all
right so the movie you've been waiting
for in first place for our poster
competition 46 posters this time very
good at $1,000 for first prize is Gurjit
Sethi Mukherjee at Sethi with the poster
identifying the prospects of
electrochemical ammonia synthesis using
first principles and
really bad handwriting so let's have a
round of applause for Gary off Sethi
Thank You great so with that I want to
congratulate all of you with posters and
please stay with us for the next little
bit we're gonna have a fantastic talk
our speaker for six o'clock has arrived
so we'll be going right into that and we
have a reception immediately following
thank you okay we're not going to
connect this okay so this is just
no no buts but we want this for the
background up here break yeah please
hopefully people will stay to hear the
NASA the Allegheny cleantech prize folks
that's a big prize okay so before we
announce the three winners I want to
invite Paul Jaffe from the Naval
Research Lab who will announce the
semi-finalists for the DoD competition
special prize surprise Thank You Sen
appreciate the introduction as should I
mentioned I'm Paul Jaffe from the US
Naval Research Laboratory and I am here
is the representative from the
Department of Defense and looking at
energy projects with regard to their
applicability for Department of Defense
needs so it's no surprise I'm sure to
you to know that a lot of pain and
danger goes into providing energy to our
forces and those that work to to keep us
safe and that fight for our country as a
result there's a DoD prize track and the
three teams that have been selected here
will go on to the final competition
there were a couple requirements for the
do deprives the first was that a team
must have a prototype of whatever their
innovation or technology is and that it
should address the key driver of
reducing mass and volume of the energy
supplies that we need to move forward it
also needs to be easy to use able to be
rapidly deployed and durable so to this
end there were three teams that
exhibited a addressing these needs the
first one I'm pleased to say is waste
list tech from Penn State good have a
team represent
so as you saw from their presentation
waste less tax innovation reduces the
volume of water this unit so if you can
imagine just like cutting down ideally
by 90% the number of tanks tanker trucks
full of water that we might have to
bring forward would be great
the second team is grapefruit from CMU
their approach to monitoring controlling
and potentially reducing energy that's
used in theater is very valuable again
any amount of fuel that we can reduce is
important for DoD and perhaps most
important and we actually hear this like
I hear this when I talk to the Marines
and the army they say you know we have a
real problem we can't even monitor how
much energy we're using and where we're
using it so the innovation from grid
fruit is a really good step towards
doing that for for our forces so
congratulations so then the final team
in the defense track is square line
power from West Virginia University
their innovation allows soldiers to
potentially easily recharge equipment
without it's getting dirty without
requiring bulky power cabling that is
prone to failure and it also offers a
promise potentially of a drone that you
could recharge without having to plug it
in or to unplug it so is there anyone
still here from square line power all
right well if you would accept it on
their behalf that would be fantastic so
in as many many of you are having a
closure now to to wireless power as a
thing in the consumer world obviously
there's applications for DoD as well so
great thank you okay the winners of the
prototype fries and the 2500 also
developed their prototypes are boundary
labs Case Western wind turbine drag
reduction tomato announced all of them
together yeah a great food from Carnegie
Mellon intelligence software for
commercial building refrigeration expiry
ml Carnegie Mellon artificial
intelligence for better batteries the
fan favorite oh sorry oh yeah
[Applause]
oh yeah but these guys are too tall
[Laughter]
[Applause]
fan-favorite winner of $5,000 prize is
kppen state solar cell technology team
from Colton stage investor Maryland
[Applause]
I think this is yeah what is that third
[Music]
[Applause]
so surprise third place for the
Allegheny region clean tech competition
and winner of $5,000 price boundary labs
from Case Western
[Applause]
thank you
second place and winner of $10,000 prize
ecotone from Carnegie Mellon
[Applause]
first place and winner of $50,000 prize
waste less technology from Penn State
[Applause]
okay
so that ends the Allegheny region
competition and I will turn for him to
Anna to introduce the next
good evening I'm very excited to be able
to present to you our speaker for this
evening and the kickoff of
sustainability weekend so we at an
energy week are extremely excited that
we've had this opportunity to partner
with sustainability weekend including
Tamara Amend who's here in the front to
put together some exceptional
programming for this sort of crossover
event and so this evening I would
actually like to welcome to the stage
Balaji Ganapathy he is the head of
workforce effectiveness and oversees the
functions of HR business consulting
diversity and inclusion corporate social
responsibility for over 335 thousand
employees of the tata consultancy
services services in north america his
primary responsibilities include
coaching sales and business teams for
business growth driving talent
management and retention initiatives
leading the corporate social
responsibility strategy and incubating a
culture of inclusion
Balaji serves as a chair of the stem
connectors STEM innovation task force
chairperson of n powers TCC Advisory
Council vice chair of the million wim
mentor will million women mentors
Leadership Council Executive Committee
of impact 2030 World Economic Forum's
education steering committee and as part
of the US Chamber of Commerce's
education employment and training
committee as head of HR for global R&D
he's part of Tatas corporate technology
board with a mandate for
institutionalizing a culture of
innovation across the organization which
makes him the perfect guest speaker
based on sustainability weekend's themes
of equity diversity and sustainability
inclusion as team of as head of HR 40
CSS corporate Learning Center he led a
team responsible for onboarding and
integrating over 12,000 campus hires I
am very pleased to welcome
Balaji to the stage
thank you good evening everybody that's
happy all right so very happy to be here
and thanks to Carnegie Mellon for
inviting me to speak to you and share
some of my thoughts and perspectives
about equity diversity inclusion and a
few other things I hope you'll have
questions because I've prepared for half
an hour and I hope the rest of the time
we'll spend in interacting with each
other a couple of things I thought of
and I was sitting here watching these
young upcoming professionals come up and
present on stage and share their
concepts it took me about 20 years when
I did the same and it's really
invigorating to be an entrepreneur and
have amazing concepts that can change
the world mine was on a fuel cell
powered car which you know goes and very
well aligned with the theme of clean
energy and reducing energy consumption
overall but some of the things that I
learned during that time stay with me
even today 2025 years later the second
thing I want to mention before I kick
off my session is the great relationship
between TCS and CMU very thankful for
this partnership this amazing
partnership two years ago TCS made a 35
million dollar endowment to CMU and as a
result of that we're starting to see the
vibrant innovation that's going to
happen around the areas of robotics or
dorama systems and artificial
intelligence and so many other digital
technologies that are powering today's
economy and that's going to be the how
I'm going to frame my session and talk
about education
as a really a great lever for Economic
Opportunity and the role of digital
technologies within that that's what I'm
here to share the message around so when
I entered the workforce I in fact I was
an entrepreneur before I joined TCS so
when I entered the workforce the kind of
things that were being talked about
where email having you know access to
email itself was a great thing having
access to a computer to do something was
even better and technology meant
something else in today's world
technology means something incredibly
different right you think about what has
happened over the past two three decades
in terms of the proliferation of
Technology and also the rate at which it
has been adopted and commercialized for
business good as well as societal good
it's incredible so we live in a time
where we are able to use buzzwords like
big data and analytics and Internet of
Things and just doesn't stay as a
buzzword it's actually practically
applicable very much approachable and
accessible to people to create
innovations around and commercialize it
and also use it for social good so we
live in a very interesting time so what
does the future look like the future is
here and now is my first message to you
and that's evident in the kind of
presentations that you saw from the
upcoming researchers and undergraduate
master students at CMU and other
universities who are represented here
they've brought the best of innovation
and applied that into social problems
that they saw around them but the future
is here and now also because like I said
these are not buzzwords these are
technologies that are powering solutions
within enterprises within countries we
communities and when I think about the
resurgence of a city like Pittsburgh you
can certainly say that a lot of this has
to do with the technology uplift that
has happened right so so the future is
here and now that's my first message to
you and when you think about the
opportunities that lie ahead there's
tremendous possibilities that are there
for us to really harness and utilize the
potential of so some of you will be
familiar with the concept of the fourth
Industrial Revolution and what that
means and for those who have heard of it
but want to understand more I have a
short video to play
now okay that's fine
I'll do a one-minute summary of that the
fourth Industrial Revolution is
basically following the first three the
first three many of you may be familiar
with but the use of steam to really
drive a production and productivity was
the first Industrial Revolution the
Second Industrial Revolution was the use
of electricity to commercialize and then
again increase productivity but bring in
some mechanization and machine ization
into society and the third Industrial
Revolution is all about computers and
information technology and the ability
of those technologies to then again
enhance societal growth and productivity
right what is happening today is that we
are in the early stages of the fourth
Industrial Revolution and what is so
different between this particular
innovation cycle which is known as the
fourth Industrial Revolution and others
is that it is happening in a space where
three different areas intersecting right
you have technology that is in the is in
desert intersecting with nature and
biology and also systems so you have
three different elements coming together
and the opportunities that then become
available for the kind of innovation
that Heian can happen is completely
different so that's what you're seeing
in rapid advances for example in drug
discovery Bionic calms you on the other
side you're seeing rapid advances in
things like autonomous vehicles and what
it can do
UAVs and yesterday I was reading about
the success of a small start-up not
small anymore a startup called zipline
that's using drones to deliver blood to
people in Rwanda right so the
availability of these technologies and
what it's doing is flipping them the
whole innovation model upside down right
so as an organization let me shift gears
and think about it from an organized
perspective right as an organization
water said that we do in order to you
know really harness the power of these
technologies that's what I want to spend
a few minutes on and then that will lead
to my next session next part of the
session which is more around what does
that mean for society at large and what
role do each of us have to play within
that right so we from a company
perspective we look at this and the way
our thought leadership framework is laid
out we call it as business for auto and
business for darto is all about we are a
b2b company a technology company that's
providing digital services to fourteen
hundred watching thousand companies
around the world right so when we view
it what we are saying is that these
technologies are helping us take our
customers who are enterprises be more
intelligent agile automated and on the
cloud and what is behind each of those
four technology LED innovations
intelligent means having not just access
to data but converting that data into
insights and using analytics to lead us
to data base and evidence based
approaches to decision making right
that's what being intelligent
Enterprises is all about being agile
means able to move away from an
innovation cycle where you had to wait
for months and years to see technology
lead change happen and be able to do it
in incremental incremental E as you grow
your enterprise right and so for those
of you who have been on the corporate
side you can understand the challenges
involved in technology projects all
right these are never on time never on
budget and by the time you get to the
point where the software system is
implemented its need is already gone I
see somebody smiling in the audience
yeah you
you felt the pain you've seen it happen
but what the agile based methodologies
allow us to do is to cut through all of
that and basically interact directly
between people who are owning the
product to people who are designing the
product right so that's the second
technological innovation that we are
tapping into the third one is being
automated which means that the resources
that are available within the
organization can then be prioritized to
something bigger than what it is
currently dedicated to whether it is
Human Resources technology resources
intellectual resources financial
resources you can do that if you think
of it from a machine first delivery
model which is what we bring to the
table as an organization and there are
ramifications of that but the fourth
element of it is cloud and again many of
you are familiar with these technologies
whether it is public cloud private cloud
hybrid clouds and the ability for you to
be accessing data real time in places
where you know that the resilience of
that data when any external interactions
happen is very high right so it's it's
transformative not just for large
enterprises it's also transformative for
small and medium businesses and to be
able to do that
think of the move to cloud as how we
dealt with y2k and what happened during
that time right and the the model of
having a factory based approach to
looking at what systems existed and
moving them and migrating them into new
set of systems that's what's happening
today with the move to cloud of course
cloud has much more potential than that
but the early adoption of cloud is
happening in this space so if these are
the four technology innovations or
technology drivers behind business 4.2
there are four behavioral elements which
hasn't changed since the first
Industrial Revolution it continues to
remain the same
but the very interpret and use it has
changed over time so if you look at it
today mass customization or tailoring it
to the segment of one this has always
been the case if you look at 20 30 years
ago businesses where again all about
putting the customer at the center of
everything that you do right so it's not
very different but what has happened
today
is because of the availability of these
technologies you are able to make that
kind of customization and
personalization in a seamless manner in
a more cost-effective manner in a manner
where you can play around and scale
things pretty quickly in a manner where
you are able to see results and the
feedback loop is much faster right so
mass customization and this for example
if you look at what's happening with
retail and the whole shopping experience
or with travel and how we interact with
air travel or when you go on a cruise
all of that is one of the first few
adoptions and manifestations of mass
customization the second aspect is
creating exponential value which means
that using the limited resources or the
resources that are available to have a
multiplier effect and that's what is the
second concept again something very
linked to productivity but in this is
not just about productivity this is
about growth and transformation and
that's what thinking about it from a
exponential value perspective brings him
right so the exponential value to larges
lines of business within customers but
the entire enterprise right and the
third element is leveraging ecosystem so
today you're collaborating across
functions and when I when I first
learned about this and a couple of days
ago when I heard the introductory speech
by your president
he mentioned the word interdisciplinary
and I think that's where liberating
ecosystems comes into play because you
had no longer siloed within the
boundaries of a discipline or a unit or
a business line but you are actually
liberating ecosystems not just within
your organization but we have a co
innovation network where we have the
searchers
we have startups we have academic
institutions research institutions all
of that that you can tap into as you are
thinking about innovating a new product
or a service or an offering right so and
these ecosystems are tremendous if you
are able to tap into for example public
infrastructure systems and have that
interact with data that you have within
your organization and create something
of value for a town or a community think
of what it can do right so earlier you
could imagine that but you couldn't
deliver it because the constraints that
were placed by the technological
challenges today you don't have that
anymore right
so the fourth element is embracing risk
and this is all about our journey as an
organization to reinvent ourselves every
few years or every few decades we've
been in businesses the fiftieth year of
existence and if you meet people who
have been 20 30 years in the company
offices there are a lot you ask them how
was how are things when you started with
the company you get tremendous stories
that that that didn't bring a lot of
historical perspective of the change
that happens within organizations
technology companies in information
technology companies and where we are
today so this the embracing risk is also
about being able to channel those
thoughts and culture to help our
customers also embrace that risk but do
that in a way that's very diligent right
they're able to embrace that risk pilot
new ideas new technologies new offerings
which you can see an immediate effect on
the custom
site also and this is happening all
around the world this is not just
isolated to the US this is happening
Europe UK companies around the world are
doing this right
so in summary all of this can happen
only if we harness the abundance that is
in the middle of this whole new
ecosystem an abundance means from our
point of view abundance of talent and
abundance of opportunities right as the
company but when I if I now shift focus
and look at the abundance that is
available around us in the world and
wear that hat it's amazing we keep
thinking about the challenges that we
face as a society three billion people
employed again seven billion citizens
around the world and if you look at the
UN sustainable development goals that
will give you a gold sheet of how the
world can become a better place right 17
goals that speak to the challenges that
exist around the world but the resources
are also available on the other side
right so whether it is talent whether it
is technology whether it is access to
better infrastructure better thought
process better so many things have
changed so in that context if I think
about a person living today and have
wanting to participate in this new
economy in this new fourth Industrial
Revolution economy there is a bridge
that we need to put in place and the
bridge is needed because the way our
education systems and society has
prepared people over the past 100 plus
years to participate with veteran
organizations or be entrepreneurs and
business people on their own that's not
going to work anymore it worked really
well for
and agrarian era it worked in a pretty
good way for the industrial era but the
demands that are being placed on young
people as they come up through life a
very different today I look at my own
daughter and I wonder you know at the
day when she's gonna ask the question
that I have
I can't Google up right it's gonna
happen someday because kids are much
more smarter they have access to more
information they fail fast fail early
early on in their life so they're
learning resilience and how to learn and
they're coming up with all of these kind
of mindsets in order to face the world
but if we corner them or if we put them
into a system that is not meant to
provide the kind of experiences that is
required to participate in the new
economy that is a challenge right so
that's something that all of us have to
think about and this is not to say any
system is good or bad it is what it is
today even more what worries me is that
the people who are not participating in
the economies of trading right if you
are here in the room we are really
privileged to be part of that society
where we know what our roles are what we
could do well and we're doing this think
of the underserved and underrepresented
parts of society where today they don't
have access to these opportunities
because the education and the awareness
that is required for people to get there
it's not there today right so think of
that for a moment and think of how we
can advance that so that's what I'm
going to spend the next few minutes
talking about and I want to start with
three metrics for you to frame this
problem right one is that if you look at
the world of today this was a statistic
that is from three years ago still
through today 35 percent of core skills
that are required in career
and opportunities of 2020 are changing
during a five-year period which means
that this is our world changing from
under our feet what was my first message
the future is here and now and it's
happening for people who are employed of
people who are entrepreneurs who are
doing these businesses the way they have
to interact with organizations the way
how they have to think about innovation
commercialization all of that has
changed and it's changing rapidly so as
an organization there are some
responsibilities that we have as society
there are some responsibilities that we
have to understand what these changes
are and make sure that these are signals
that are passed on from the world of
work to the world of Education and
beyond
do you agree the second statistic is
that 65 percent of students who are
entering primary school today are going
to be in jobs that do not exist yet how
do you prepare a world where you don't
know what the jobs of the future are
going to look like and believe me these
kids who are participating these
opportunities they know where to go they
know how to go but as society if you
look at it in scale and the disparate
systems that exist across countries and
across continents then the problem that
we're dealing with is totally different
right so not only do we have to envisage
the future and understand what is what
what that win is going to look like we
then have to translate it backwards to
how this is unfold and what can we do
today that can prepare people for that
future tomorrow right and the third
element I'll put in front of you the
third statistic to frame this problem is
that I mentioned earlier that technology
also come
with some challenges right and many of
us have seen and heard the doomsday
scenarios of millions of jobs are going
to be lost because of automation and new
technology adoption but I don't
subscribe to that view entirely the
thing the element of truth that is there
there are two elements of truth one is
that what we call as a job is going to
change so the skills that are required
while some may remain and some part of
that work will remain some part of that
work will go away and as you can imagine
it is going to be the mundane and the
repetitive aspects of what we do today
in our jobs that is going to change but
as a result of that there are going to
be some work streams some career paths
some jobs that will disappear and that's
been the case with every Industrial
Revolution that's happened the second
element of truth which is troubling is
that if you are a woman or if you are a
person from a minority background the
impact on you is going to be much higher
and that's where the burden of what is
going to happen is going to fall on
those who already don't have what it the
kind of support that is needed or the
opportunities that are needed right but
even with all of that I believe that we
have a great future ahead of us because
I don't believe that machines are going
to take over I believe that it's going
to be the people like you and me we're
going to determine where our world heads
next of course that means that we need
to be responsible we need to think about
what kind of boundaries we put around
how we innovate and doing it in a way
that is not just fair and just but also
equitable right so how are we doing that
and what what kind of thoughts can I
bring to the tables from the experiences
that we have had as an organization
to bring to this discussion and then I
will open it up for questions and
interaction on what other ideas we could
have so as a company with 380,000
employees around the world we have a few
things that work really well for us it
is the talent and the abundance of
talent that is the starting point so
rather than look at this as a problem of
you know do we need these many employees
what's going to happen it implies in the
future we looked at it as an opportunity
to prepare the same set of employees for
a new tomorrow the second thing is
130,000 employees are women against a
sector where the representation is about
twenty four percent today in the u.s.
most good companies are doing a
twenty-two percent in the tech sector
that's no great shakes but you need to
do better we need to create more
pathways which I'll address in a
subsequent slide 133 nationalities which
means that the cultural competencies
that are required in the world of work
of tomorrow we have that in abundance
and 50 markets so market knowledge also
we have in abundance so that's what we
look at as our strengths as an
organization so if you view your own
personal strengths in the context of
where we are and where we are going
that's a good starting point then what
do you do with it this is just a summary
2.2 million people have been reached
through the work that we're doing over
the past few years and we've invested
close to 200 million dollars in societal
initiatives but even more important is
that we're doing walking the talk within
the organization also over five hundred
thousand half a million new digital
competencies that we have developed just
in the past couple of years and over a
million certifications what does that
mean it means if I framed the problem I
knew I was going to come up with some
solution also to offer the solution that
we have to offer is
that in the world of the fourth
Industrial Revolution and using business
for auto as a thought leadership
framework we believe that we can harness
abundance to empower communities that is
our worldview and how do we do that we
do that in three ways you can do that by
starting within your organization's
rescaling and upskilling employees so
that they can participate in the world
of today and tomorrow
preparing young people for opportunities
and that means interacting with
education and social systems that exists
here and around the world the third of
the most important thing is making sure
that all of this is done with a lens of
equity and access so that the people
that we are trying to reach and impact
first are the ones who are getting at
least today ok with me so far now now
I'm gonna give you some examples of how
we're doing it and hopefully that will
give you some food for thought
and also something to reflect on as we
get into the discussion part of this
session
we bring building cross-functional to
skills you know when the title of the
session is transdisciplinary education
I'm sure you know I'm gonna walk the
talk when it comes to that from the
organization's side see if you view it
as a triangle what we are saying is that
what we are channeling to our employees
and to customer executives who are
talking to us also what we are saying is
that in the new world of work you need
knowledge deep knowledge from a
technical sense deep knowledge from a
domain sense and deep knowledge from a
contextual sense knowledge of Technology
is something you can easily gain by
going to a course gaining a
certification knowledge of domain is
something you gain not just by attending
a course by work working in a say for
example in energy company you gain
domain knowledge right but the third
element which is the power of your
existing workforce and people who are
already at work is the contextual
knowledge of how to do what to do and
all of this coming together is what is
powering the business for our journey
that we're having and that means giving
people access to educational and
training opportunities where they are
when they want so if I go from here to
my hotel in Pittsburgh this evening and
it takes 15 minutes what can I learn
that is bite-sized and that's useful for
me I open up my phone I have a fresco
play app which is tool that PCs uses and
I scroll down to machine learning that
sounds interesting everybody seems to be
talking about it nowadays so what does
that mean in 15 minutes I can gain basic
knowledge of what that is and that tells
me whether this is something that have
aptitude for something I want to pursue
further and then I graduate to the next
level by signing up for a course it can
be a web based course it can be a
virtual one or I can attend it in an
external forum so providing layers
opportunity for layers of competencies
and skills to be gained is how we are
breaking this down and democratizing it
basically you're democratizing both
access to these opportunities as well as
proficiency how you gain proficiency in
these skills and competencies so that's
the first part the second part when it
comes to external and now the rest of my
session is all going to be about
externally what we do in the community
and how we can interact through
probability public-private partnerships
and other means it's all about three
things context which if you remember I
said is the most important aspect
content and connection that's in summary
we do with the external world in terms
of community engagement and some
examples of how we do that is what I'm
going to describe to you the first one
is go IT couldn't be more happier
passionate about a program and go ID
this is next year is our tenth year of
running this program this is in summary
a program that helps young people and
people from disadvantaged and
underrepresented backgrounds and
under-resourced parts the society to
stop being just consumers of technology
and start being creators and innovators
of technology how do you do that very
simply translating what you saw before
this in terms of the wonderful
presentations and concepts that many of
your teams brought up here and showed
and translating it to a k-12 environment
that's pretty much it
why because some of you who are here in
the room still know the passion and what
it comes with when you the Eureka moment
that occurs when you are able to see
yourself using something that you
learned to solve a problem that is
persisting you that's what go IT does we
help students define a problem that they
see around them or if they cannot we
offer them one from what we have seen in
the community or nationally and then put
them in teams and first of all start
with empathy if you look at what the
World Economic Forum said is going to be
one of the top skills for 2020 how many
have you seen if you've not seen that
you should go and look at that the tops
one of the top skills is emotional
intelligence right starts with empathy
being able to relate and put yourself in
the shoes of somebody else going through
that problem but then being able to see
this is
see it and see how you can address that
starts with that then goes into human
centered design so we teach them design
thinking and we have narrowed it and we
have you know really being able to
abstract it to a way where within 20
hours these students are able to absorb
these concepts apply them on a problem
of their choice come up with solutions
present those solutions and then get
excited about working on it after we
leave this with inner-city neighborhoods
and rural parts of the country where let
alone a technology course or something
around computer science many of those
school systems don't even have the
resources that are needed to do that so
that's where you can have transformative
change when you apply something that you
know can work really well but really
hone how it can do well in a place where
the need is the most so the whole
innovation process that happens within
go IT is mimicking what we do if you
remember the for technology leave us
with in business for Auto agile was one
of them this is mimicking the agile
methodology that we use within the
organization so they come up with
concepts wireframes storyboards quickly
program and see how that solution comes
to life using technology and then get
feedback immediately so that they can
iterate and improve upon those and
that's what they do in New York region
this is run in 58 cities across the u.s.
and Canada and has grown to many
countries outside of the US and Canada
as well today
in the New York Region we decided to use
the platform that we have as the title
sponsor of the New York City Marathon to
bring some of these kids and share the
concepts that they had similar to how
some of you shared
in front of an esteemed audience we
asked them to think about problems
around health around wellness around
nutrition the five boroughs and a few
cities outside of New York City and ask
them to come up and pitch this in front
of CEOs of healthcare organizations of
companies that are involved in running
and led runners themselves let's see how
they did we'll play the video
[Music]
these kids were brought together through
TTS is Bill IT a program that encourages
students to pursue stem degrees the end
game out is just to inspire students and
get them interested in computer science
specifically shows and that they can be
producers of the big things every day
not just consumers
it's home I love this because my dad was
good
I can help to go today by not making my
neck question because a lot
[Music]
yes
so that's just an example of what you
can do by bringing industry context and
pairing up mentors with young kids this
particular team was from the Bronx but
there were teams from across all the
boroughs that competed in this challenge
but the idea is not just to provide the
challenge and the opportunity for people
to engage but to provide that real-world
connect right that gives the context
they're able to say that ok this is not
just something that I'm learning to
write a test this is something that I'm
going to use this is going to stay with
me for life problem-solving skills the
communication skills the team-building
skills and you asked me as an employer
what is lacking in in you know that I
would like to fix among people that we
hire it is those skills you ask any
employer around the world at least 70 80
percent of the time will get the same
answer so providing that context puts
them on a path where even if you are not
there they cannot stop thinking about
how they can apply these concepts that
they have learned these techniques that
they have learned to problems that is
here on them so it develops a way of
thinking now the second example I want
to share with you is ignite my future in
school and this was born out of the need
that exists across America that many of
you may be aware of many of you may not
be aware of we are sitting of course
here in CMU which boasts being the top
computer science school in the country
and possibly the world but do you know
that less than 20% of schools across
America have even access to a
pure science course less than a million
out of the 55 million students in our
public education system or even being
offered something that you can refer to
as a computer
computational thinking or computer
science concepts yet as employers as
industry we predict that computational
thinking not just computer science
computer science is the ultimate
reflection of that but if you look at
the breadth of skills that are needed
computational thinking is going to be a
foundational skill required for any job
any carrier any sector why because it is
the new problem-solving methodology of
the 21st century
it's not that it is new in terms of a
concept and a science it's been in
existence for many years now but it's
capturing the public imagination because
it is giving a way for us to define this
and say that in order to interact with
machines in order to interact with these
things that we are creating you need to
know how to talk to it right you need to
know how to look at data how to make
sense of it how to abstract it how to
model the data and these are not just
needed if you are a computer scientist
or a computer science engineer these are
problem-solving skills that you need as
a citizen of the world of today and
tomorrow
only then will you be able to appreciate
what's happening around us and how these
digital technologies are impacting you
right so we said how do we go about
doing this how do we go about bringing
computational thinking in an ecosystem
where computer science itself has a
challenging presence so many years for
many years we've been working with
efforts like cs4 all and other national
and regional efforts to advance computer
science education working with senators
and Congress persons at the hill to
promote policy that will allow for
computer science to be introduced into
high schools in the middle schools the
move needle is moving but it is moving
really slowly we don't have time for
that as a country as a society because
the students who are coming out of the
education system today need it as much
as when the policy comes into effect
maybe a few years from now so it is up
to us as citizens as industry as garment
as educational institutions as civic
society to take up and take charge of
this so one solution that we offered for
that is to partner with a reputable
educational organization called
Discovery Education
he said let's develop a program that
brings computational thinking into the
classroom but the difference is that
we're not going to ask teachers to do
something new we're not going to ask
teachers to change their entire
curriculum you're not going to ask them
to do one more thing because if there is
any group of people in the country that
are underappreciated it is the teachers
they are carrying the weight of systemic
challenges that has plagued the system
so how do we make them ambassadors of
this new approach how do we empower them
that was the thought process so we
developed a set of resources that will
bring computational thinking into core
subjects so that whether you're teaching
math science arts humanities English
language any subject that you are
teaching as a teacher there are 3.5
million of those across the country any
subject you can today teach
computational thinking using these
lesson plans using these resources what
does that do it creates an opportunity
for people to not
isolated and be left out not thing that
they want the best if anybody wants the
best for our students it is the teachers
because the parents are there
we have biased right we gave birth to
them it's the teachers for doing it
altruistically so how about empowering
them and so what we did is we developed
these resources and lesson plans there
are 40 of these today available on
ignite my future dot o-r-g ignite my
future in school dot o-r-g I am sorry
and what you can do as a teacher is gain
access to any one of these lesson plans
and use it in the classroom but he said
okay you can't build it and expect
people to use it so we also launched a
grass root level effort where we are now
partnering with ten pilot districts
across the country to bring this to a
school and the entire school district
some of the early adopters include the
Dallas Independent School District
Harrisburg Pennsylvania with Janesville
Wisconsin New York City there are three
districts that are adopting it Charlotte
North Carolina I can name places across
the country that are saying that this
opportunity is something that we have to
make yourself and so teachers get a full
day of professional development so they
are not just getting a chance to
understand this new concepts and how
they can use it in the classroom because
it's by choice no one is mandating them
no one is going to tell them that if you
don't use this something's gonna happen
this is by choice but when you do that
can you help them plan their lessons
planned their weeks plan their pedagogy
in such a way that it makes it easy and
accessible for them to do it and that's
what that day does and then at the end
of the day we bring in parents and
members of the community for a community
night that they can see the power of
these concepts in action
they see drones and robos and other
things interact with them but then they
get to do some family exercises which
demystifies that so curriculum and
courses and resources professional
development and through partnerships and
community nights that act as that lever
for change in the in the local
communities and yesterday we had the
opportunity to talk to our friends at
CME and hopefully the program will come
to Pittsburgh and to the school systems
here and around Pennsylvania also in the
near future we hope we had committed to
do that these lessons plans as I said
are available if you have a teacher who
wants to make use of this please contact
us through the website there are
certification modules also available so
if you want to learn about the seven
foundational principles behind
computational thinking even for you I
found it pretty interesting to refresh
those concepts you can go there you can
view it it's all self-paced modules with
pre and post surveys to help you gauge
how much you have learned but if you are
a teacher wanting to use this in the
classroom that's not it that's not all
that we're doing we're having learning
leaders and a network and a community of
leaders we created so that both in the
location that they are internationally
they are part of a larger community okay
most of us are familiar with social
networks but for teachers it makes a
huge difference because if they hear
from another teacher what they did and
how it worked the contextual knowledge
of how they can apply it comes about and
that's what we're doing through those
learning leaders and through those
networks so couldn't be happier with
this partnership we launched it with a
goal and a vision to reach a million
students in five years and 20,000
teachers sounded ambitious we started in
this school year
twenty
in September we've already reached 2,500
plus teachers and 150,000 students so we
believe that this is something that's
really powerful that can change the way
in which people learn in a
transdisciplinary way so not as silos of
math and science and arts and humanities
but use computational thinking as a
common framework to bring all of this
together and I and you know there are
some impact measurements also if you're
interested in that I'm happy to talk
about it as on in the Q&A part now for a
video of how this is working in the
Dallas school system
[Music]
to be at this first day of discovery and
really see ignite my future come to life
is one of those moments
I'm simply through the work that I do
the careers of the future are changing
almost faster than we can keep up with
them and it's exciting for our children
and we're excited for them and we want
to do as much as we can to help them not
only be prepared to be amazing human
beings but also to be agile in the
workforce and to have lots of really
cool skills to pull from we are going to
set the stage for this country around
this particular
we have to do this where the country is
going the world is going we really have
to give our students this opportunity
and the way that we do it is we teach
our teachers this will be something
really transformative and if anything I
think the kids will come back and say
finally like I can really show you what
I can do I can show you what I know you
let me do something that I feel like I'm
really good at they can really
articulate the knowledge that you have
given you you know a lot of times people
said let's get our kids ready for 21st
century skills or get that we're heading
to the 22nd century now and the more
that we can expose them to the
methodology and thinking the process
behind it the easier it is for them to
apply it to different mediums the
challenges we face as human beings on
planet Earth today really do require
creative collaborative adaptable
solutions we want to celebrate what
you're doing in the classroom and most
importantly we want you to be able to
share that celebration with other
teachers I think it's a good way to open
up the channels of communication
haven't been previously explored and the
whole idea of a sense of community if we
can have more of an online community
then we can be working more
collaboratively the gate is open like
someone has taken the tea and let you
application take off for an NSC where
you wind up back in the day we needed to
prepare our kids to play jeopardy now we
need a having the rifle questions so I
just say hats off
tremendous thank you to talkto into
discovery we're actually investing in
American education and what we're trying
to do and really having us just eight
larger think bigger think bolder think
grander in five years these kids are
gonna say thank you for teaching me how
to think
[Music]
the last part i want to mention is that
content and context is not enough you
need to have connections so that once
they have the knowledge of how to use
these skills have the right kind of
foundational skills be available not
just through after-school and all the
school experiences but within the school
system itself you also need to connect
to carriers of today and tomorrow and
that's where what we've been engaged in
is to power the technology
infrastructure as well as create grass
root level efforts along with partners
from industry and from the other by
other sectors of society and again these
are efforts that span across the country
across all regions across all
demographics but three specific
initiatives I want to mention is oneness
million women mentors which is an effort
to help advance girls and young women in
STEM disciplines and careers and again
here the metrics are pretty ominous the
wage gap is real the education gap is
even more real right so how do you build
bridges and opportunities and that's
what this particular effort is doing
both through grass root level efforts
where companies are identifying mentors
who can engage with young girls and
women but also as these young women into
the workforce the statistic also says
that 50% the drop-off within the stem
workforce for women happens in the first
ten years so what do you do to improve
persistence
how can you pal them up with internal
mentors within the organization sponsors
who can help them at once so those are
all efforts that are going on happy to
share that when we started we wanted to
reach a million that was we started in
2015 and by 2017 we had crossed that
million today we are at 2 million
pledges for mentors and men
for this effort and we already crossed 1
million actual mentor-mentee engagements
that have been reported across the
country so again very much
aspirational scale effort to bring this
to attention and engage from an industry
perspective the second one is us 2020
which is again effort that is built
around students of colors and students
from minority groups but high-impact
mentoring so you're looking at a city
like say for example Boston or Chicago
or even smaller towns and seeing what is
the baseline for stem mentoring that
exists today how do you grow that how do
we do that in partnership with smaller
organizations that understand the
problems and are best suited to find
solutions to it and that's what's
happening with this effort about 17
cities across the country are involved
in it every year with the previous
administration every year we were giving
out stem mentoring or Watts at the White
House hoping to continue that with this
new administration as well empower is
the final one I want to mention
disadvantaged youth so if you are
looking at the early part of the system
the middle part of the system if you
look at disadvantaged youth which is
between 18 and 24 and unemployed right
there are a lot of those youth also in
the country that need to be addressed
and which is what this organization
called empower is doing they are
headquartered out of New York but have
operations across multiple cities in the
country
and the focus is to have a 22-week
curriculum that can help provide
technology skills that make them
employable that's the crux of it but the
focus is on disadvantaged youth and
veterans so those are the three examples
they wanted to share with you I want to
summarize this whole session by starting
there restarted that the future is here
and now which means that we need to act
at the pace of innovation not at the
regular pace that we have been at so if
we have to increase our pace we need to
have sustainable solutions but scalable
solutions also and it is possible
if a company like us with our partners
can do it with your brainpower and the
knowledge and wisdom that you have we
can do so much more right but it needs
us to really come together to cross
boundaries and sit together to look at
these solutions and think of scale and
impact and sustainability at the get-go
not start the effort and then do that
later which I thought was well
represented in many of your students
concentrations they thought about where
this is going a few years from now had
the same mentality is what we need in
these social efforts the second is
providing education whether it is in
college school or in general because you
don't stop learning just because you're
not attending this school right so in
general lifelong learning as a mentality
as a culture means access to education
that is of course it has to be fun and
engaging but also that is relevant
relevant to the need of today and
tomorrow and that is contextual
investing in building resilient
populations so cities like Pittsburgh
communities need to look at where they
are today the jobs disappearing will
happen in some communities but we can't
fight it alone we have to come together
and think of how do you build resilience
and skills and access to skills and in a
good education contextual relevant
education can make that difference so we
need to think of that and look at
multi-year efforts to advance that and
finally I want to end with the
positivity that they said you know I am
extremely a beat about the future
because it is humans are going to
control what happens next and if we can
harness this abundance we can
democratize possibility every person can
have access to opportunities if you
really put our minds against it and do
it in a collaborative manner and that's
what I want to share with you thank you
for being with me and sharing these
thoughts I look forward to hearing your
questions thank you
we have an app that where we've been
collecting questions throughout the
session so we'll just do a couple of
them the good news is that we have a
reception immediately following and so
folks can talk with you directly and ask
you some additional questions like that
so the first question is someone wants
to thank you and TCS for the incredible
support of CMU
both students and faculty can embracing
risk and change be incentivized in large
operations that's a good point and this
is where everybody wants to change but
everybody wants change but nobody wants
to change right so incentives and
culture are so important this is what I
learned
part of my bio involved being the head
of HR for our CTO and R&D group and
researchers as you can imagine are ones
who are you know have a methodical
process a scientific approach to things
but not always the best at
commercializing ideas right so doing
research for research and advancing that
field used to be what our organization
also was focused on but through an
effort where we created bridges between
the research and the business
applicability of that we were able to
you know create a change and create a
culture where innovation incentivizing
innovation became the theme so you have
to make big bets but you have to look at
who your current audiences and embracing
risk means that you create those sort of
conditions that make it easy for people
to embrace risk if you performance
management systems or your appraisal
systems are going to Bing you if you
fail then you're not going to have a
culture where people feel free to
embrace that risk so you have to have
the right kind of culture right kind of
behaviors and incentivize those through
your actions another question that we do
have some good questions with its strong
itback
heritage how will TCS participate in the
advanced robotics business so we of
course view ourselves as a services
organization that powers other
organizations and their effort so it's
primarily going to be collaborative in
nature and even today some of the
advanced robotics whether it is in the
automobile sector or in the energy
sector or in oil and gas we are doing a
lot of efforts that I can't talk about
because of client confidentiality but we
are certainly right there so it is our
space will be where we can help our
customers reimagine how to move from
where they are today to adopt these
technologies and then bring it to their
customers they are in consumer so that's
the space that we're going to continue
operating in but I wish I'm looking
forward to a day when a robo will run
the New York City Marathon so that's
that's something you know I'm looking
forward to and so let's have one last
question can you tell us what as
University students we should be
thinking about what's the number one
message you'd like to leave us with stay
grounded
so somebody every time I meet someone
and I'm having this pin I get asked this
question what is this about this is the
United Nations sustainable development
goals why do I wear it because it gives
me perspective I think as students are
as individuals participating in society
that's all we need we need somebody to
remind ourselves that we are not the
work but we can help advance the world
so staying grounded having perspective
is the starting point and then the rest
of it will follow thank you thank you
all
so with that we actually are going to
conclude energy week for this week for
2018 we are planning energy week for
2019 already it will be March 25 through
29 so we look forward to seeing you in
the future but from all of us the the
team Amanda and J Whittaker and all of
us at the Scott Institute we want to
thank you for being with us this week
for those of you who are staying for
sustainability weekend we look forward
to seeing you tomorrow but otherwise
thank you very much we'll talk soon on
the other side of that wall which is our
reception thank you
[Applause]
because when you know all the chords and
everything right is this mine this is
Amanda